und wir bleiben bei corona geschaut auf
unser tägliches corona dann ja und nach
knapp einem monat lockt downlight haben
wir jetzt mittlerweile bei den zahlen
der korona infektionen eine art plateau
erreichte die zahlen sie nehmen nicht
mehr zu sie haben sich eingependelt wir
sehen es hier diese pendelbewegungen und
gleichzeitig seitwärtsbewegung wir
liegen heute bei 13.600 und vier
gemeldeten infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden ein echter abwärtstrend ist aber
so sehen wir hier deutlich aufgezeichnet
nicht in sicht schau mir auf die zahlen
und da haben wir zum einen die 13.600
und vier wir schauen uns an einmal die
hotspots haben wir hier nach wie vor
eingezeichnet in roth über 200 die
regionen da haben wir einen inzidenz
wert von über 200 da nach wie vor die
problematik und die gegenmaßnahmen
entsprechend wir schauen auf diese
hotspots hier natürlich passau aus den
letzten tagen und hildburghausen ebenso
und nürnberg kommt hinzu nürnberg ist
nämlich die zweitgrößte bayerische stadt
und ergreift strenge maßnahmen jetzt
sind hunderttausende menschen in
nürnberg aufgefordert zu hause zu
bleiben nur noch in wirklich triftigen
ausnahme gründen nach draußen zu gehen
beispielsweise zum arzt beispielsweise
zum einkaufen oder zur arbeit es gilt
außerdem in der ganzen stadt eine masken
pflicht ebenso ein alkoholverbot und
beides wird
streng kontrolliert jetzt die klinik um
das klinikum nürnberg hat jetzt sich
auch auf einen weiteren ansturm an
patienten eingestellt hat gesagt man
werde jetzt die intensivbetten
aufstocken und deswegen schauen wir
einmal noch einmal auf die
intensivbetten in nürnberg ein problem
dort wie gesagt aufgestockt nach angaben
des klinikums in dort ein halb 63
patienten corona patienten in behandlung
wir haben heute von den 27.500 18
gemeldeten betten 21.700 24 belegte
betten gemeldet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren